kaley cuoco is taking her bachelor  obsession to the next level with Ben  Higgins yoga pants the Big Bang Theory  star shared a snap enjoying the latest  episode of The Bachelor on Monday while  wearing yoga pants covered in Ben  Higgins face and signature red roses  will you accept this for us she  captioned the photo in honor of  tonight's bachelor episode I'm wearing  my one-of-a-kind Ben yoga pants  I'm obsessed and never taking them off  Ben Higgins I have questions for you  Hayley and her sister Brianna have been  huge fans of the hit ABC dating show my  sister and I started watching it and we  would just die laughing and have so much  fun and drink a little vino and like and  just love all this silly drama on  January 11th Kaylee was rendered  speechless when she called into an  episode of Bachelor live to talk to Ben  I've never been speechless I don't know  what to say then you are